welcome back to the morning toast you
guys i'm very excited to be sitting down
with someone i consider a friend but
today you're not my friend wait you
consider me just a friend
claudia claudia the woman who says
you're my best friend now it's more best
friends than i've ever met by the way
that's true i don't have a lot of best
friends okay sorry let me start over
today i'm seated down with my best
friend in the entire world the person
who i would literally give a kidney to
but today he's not that he is the
subject of international news headlines
and i wanted to get the scoop on what
the hell's going on it is brian kelly
the points guy your favorite toast guest
but today you're more than that
you're always more than that i'm on the
chopping block you're in the chopping
block okay so i have a lot i want to
talk to you about obviously like we need
to just kiki i also really want to talk
to you about housewives because there's
so much drama going on but before that
like you have been in the news quite a
bit this week and last week it's just
like really uncomfortable place for me
to be i know i know you're not used to
it i hate the spotlight
uh like really gets to me because i'm
actually an introvert you know what i
mean you're like an empath
yes it's uh you know i knew 2022 would
be an explosive year but um you know
getting getting sued by the world's
largest airline
was it exactly on that mood board that
we created i think we should we did
create a mood board and that was not on
the mood board but i think we should
just talk about it first of all what's
going on second of all like can you
break it down if someone who doesn't
keep up with travel news like what's
going on so the biggest thing you know
at the points guy you know points and
miles are confusing um you know it's a
blessing that there's so many credit
cards and bonuses but like no human can
actually read every post that we write
or you know the credit card companies
now have bonuses and rotating categories
and the airlines you know they're
actually having a lot of good things
that happened over the pandemic where
you can change your flights but it's so
confusing so we for years in-house
developed the tpg app which we launched
uh officially in september but we've
been in beta since last june
and one of the cool things about the app
is that you can tell us like what
programs you like delta or now you like
united i'm a united girly now sorry
don't at me delta delta never even
reached out to me to thank me for being
such a great customer and you know what
did united what did united do to you
is very grateful for my patronage and
that makes me feel good because when i
was in houston they literally picked me
up at the gate drove me to the centurion
lounge gave me a handwritten card told
me they appreciated my business and that
just is not something i've ever
experienced at delta so i'm just i'm
just putting it out there like delta i'm
still open like i can be bought but and
meanwhile all my friends people we're
traveling with friends here like coming
up brian does this happen to you in
every airport i open up my card from
united it's like thanks for bringing
claudia over
it wasn't even about me
[Music]
we digress not let's make everything
about us airlines look we're all it's
2022 we want to travel so the point of
the tpg app it's the only app out there
where you can get your net worth and
points and everyone that i talk to when
you take your time and you finally
connect your accounts yeah people have
tons of value the whole point of tpg why
i started this is to get people
traveling and i think that's good for
the airline business
you know we approached all the airlines
because i actually think you know to get
younger people into loyalty it's really
difficult like if they're just gonna try
to get business travelers like they need
the millennial and gen z generation and
yes use technology no and you're right
like they are missing out like right now
the points business is very much like an
older person business travel and if i
had started collecting points when i was
like 18 like traveling you know during
college i would be much better off now
yeah and
and so you know and i do think like the
gen z generation is much more educated
on like personal finance and so long
story short we launched this app and
it's amazing i've been using it for
months and it you know over time and
this is just version one like there's so
many things we want to do with it where
basically we learn where you are where
you travel and we can push alert deals
to use if you live in detroit and you're
trying to go anywhere warm in march like
we can actually
so uh but you know american came to us
and said you know we don't want to be a
part of this american american airlines
and we're like well you know you're the
world's largest airline
and you know a lot of our readers have
accounts myself included i've been an
elite so like if a consumer says hey
points guy we want you to keep track of
our account
fundamentally we just think it's the
consumer's choice i agree it's my data i
think i should decide and the airlines
have gotten away with a lot they've
bullied a lot of companies because a lot
of startups will try to do this and then
they get cease and desisted and then
they don't have the money because in our
legal system it's really expensive yeah
well they're messing with the wrong
people because you know we're a part of
red ventures which is a massive media
company we're a pro consumer we own
sites like lonely planet health line
cnet like we help consumers make
decisions that are best for them
and you know when i we're creating that
we knew that there might be friction but
you know this is what happened like
every other airline is on board correct
yeah i mean no one has ceased and
desisted us look a lot of the airlines
like we love this we don't have the tech
resources right now because we're in a
pandemic and we laid off our whole you
know department but no one has said like
you can't do this use it because the
points guy we literally we create new
loyal customers and loyal customers
credit card customers are the most
valuable how much did you spend on your
mexico ticket literally claudia spent
more on a flight to mexico shut up do
not blow up my spot it was the only seat
left
it's literally the price of like an asia
business class ticket
anywho so anyway the app has helped
consumers they said we don't want to be
a part of it we're like well
we need to do what's best for our
consumer and if all of a sudden consumer
you can only track one out of ten
airlines what's the value of that yeah
so we're kind of like all right see them
first so they ceased and assisted us and
we kind of countersued saying no like
the consumer's right to their data and
if we want to have that discussion let's
have it because a decade ago the bank so
you know you you can today you can use
mint
all sorts of financial apps that will
pull in all of your financial data and
you can make better decisions yep
that's good for consumers right we're
doing the same thing in travel and what
but when mint came in a decade ago the
banks were like no due to security you
can't do it and mint was like and just
like we're saying it's security is your
issue which they're kind of claiming you
can create an api which is a yes and
american interestingly had an api with
award wallet which is a tracking service
uh i know the founder and they just
canceled it in december or over a decade
a secure connection so this is not about
secure connections so don't let them
fool you so you decided to sue them
after they see synthetic i just think
there's a little smoking gun here and
i'm just going to say
maybe it's coincidental but i'll let you
know intelligent consumers see what's
going on so
american airlines is the only airline
that expires their members points which
is so dumb if i earn these points
they're mine forever and the airlines
sell these points for billions to credit
card companies so the consumer and get
this
they gave a reprieve over the pandemic
but april 1st of 2022 they're going to
start expiring miles again and guess
what if you haven't had activity within
18 months let's do the math from april 1
right what's back 18 months the peak of
the pandemic when people are worried
about their kids going to school like
i'm sorry not everyone's logging into
aa.com every day like
new activity
so i'm not saying it's a conspiracy but
why did they block a ward wall at their
partner of 10 years and why are they
telling tpg right before this big date
where they're going to get
you know a lot of money in expired miles
and they're gonna piss people off
because if i was an american airlines
customer for a while and obviously i
haven't traveled a lot in the last two
three years and
i find out in april that all my miles
are gonna get expired like i'm gonna be
pissed well you may not even find out
because if you're not opted into emails
or how often do you read you know how
many emails do you get from an airline
but if the tpg app which you use every
day push alerts you it says claudia your
miles next month are gonna expire here
five things to do to keep them active
today yeah no we've been talking about
your app for so long how like no-brainer
it is because i feel like the what your
app is essentially is what i use you for
i'm like ryan i have xmiles here credit
card here what do i do and you're like
oh my god i have to talk i say i created
this app so i can enjoy dinner parties
again yes so like not everyone is giving
you their whole points profile and you
have to like plan a trip to maldives for
them one of our friends from i'm helping
one of our friends from san francisco in
mexico with her point oh good
yeah like that's what you do and and
i've used the app a million times it's
so good there's literally no reason why
a brand wouldn't want to be on board
because at the end of the day like if i
and that's really what drew me to united
is like i
have paid for many many like
most like very expensive flights with
points because it pays to be loyal yeah
you use points to go to israel you get
your business class they were insanely
expensive so i just did it rome for 11.
literally live flatbeds so
this is like and i think
most people and i've had friends at the
airlines who are like we want to do this
with you but like these are just such
archaic institutions and you know to get
anything done at any humongous company
so
um so yeah so we're now so we countersu
basically said no let's take this up
we're both you know both of our
companies are incorporated in delaware
let's like hash it out and let's see
let's you know understand i also just
think it's a little egregious that
american so you know delta's actually
extended vouchers in 2022. american is
not like american you know they've been
the least customer friendly right they
have no mercy on us like we've been
through a hard time like so on the eve
of them expiring getting back to taking
away their miles members they're gonna
try to sue the points guys so we just
like you know what it's enough like
let's have the discussion yeah i think
at the end of the day as long as
consumers are aware what's going on you
know our mission is accomplished so yes
so let me ask you a question because i
was reading a lot of the comments
because i want to see because for me
it's like a no-brainer what you're doing
is you're fighting for people like us
who earn our points and just want to
keep them and just want to be able to
use them and maximize them but what is
the argument against what you're doing
like what would devil's advocate say so
the devil's advocate would say well the
airlines create these programs and we
they have terms and conditions
and just like the airlines when they
screw you over with like canceling your
flight and they owe you nothing yeah
like some people are just like
they're like the corporation knows bets
and what's best for us right no i don't
agree like at all then there's the
argument about privacy you know security
breaches data we get it so we're open
we've got a whole team ready to go
tomorrow if america wants to do a secure
api connection yeah totally get it we
can do that yeah uh and then the other i
think they're suing us over trademark
infringement and if you read the lawsuit
it's like we've worked years to build
this gorgeous brand and like if it's
seen on the points guy then it dilutes
the brand meanwhile i'm like i'm sure if
you do some brand research like who's
brand is valued more by the consumer
yeah and by the way like how dare you
that's a great brand association
i know they said like in the app we had
american airlines content meanwhile the
content is like how to get the most
value what's the best flight help
seriously it's so dumb don't kill the
messenger don't kill the messenger and
you know every time i get on a delta
airlines flight and i see your little
logo on the side of the plane i'm so
proud so you've built a great business i
appreciate you
fighting for us like if i had a hundred
thousand american airlines miles that
were gonna get expired i would be so
furious like so i didn't even know that
first of all and that's why i i don't
even think i have an american airlines
account so i'm not worried about myself
but a lot of people might yeah so if you
want to help just i would you know on
social media if you just want to tag hey
american airlines we love the points guy
like you know instead of suing the
points guy like make your planes better
you know or work with the points yeah
like
so i mean i think there's a lot better
uses of everyone's energy resources we
don't we're not a litigious company this
might you know like i would love nothing
more than to just settle this and you
know and then everyone wins they get
better customers customers use their
points more people travel more people
are loyal because they know that it pays
off everyone can win here everyone can
win now i can't let you go yet and i'm
going to do a huge shift in content
right now but there's so much going on
in the bravo housewife universe and you
are like my favorite person to giggle
and gossip about so can i get your take
on what's going on in the bravo universe
right now
yes so the jenny situation let's start
with salt lake city in general obviously
the big news yesterday was jenny
salt lake karen jenny was fired yeah
what are your thoughts so i mean i saw
some of what she posted was very
uh i mean it insensitive doesn't even
bring it up i mean she has kind of a
karen mindset yes you know like where
instead of focusing on the root cause of
protests she was like attacking looters
and then she was like joking about like
killing protesters which is just like
yeah yeah yeah and so it's it started
off with like okay you're kind of a
karen now you're so you know
as both um
people who have experienced cancer
culture i'm not you know like
in the minds that have chopped their
head off immediately
um
and i think bravo's getting heat that
they kind of did we're silencing the
other housewives jen shaw got fired for
a day but now she's back and no one was
like did you see jen shawn heather gay
someone posted it filming at the race
church yesterday meanwhile it's like the
most awkward film set now we've seen how
the sausage gets made yes it's really
awkward in person and by the way new
jersey housewives is premiering soon and
you and i like might be on an episode
well i john fazzullah was in i think one
of the uh and actually tim kush who was
there that night oh they were in the
previews well yeah you could see them
and taylor donahue oh my god it is you
didn't know that
yeah where were we
at the bar
but i'm wearing my sleeveless versace
outfit so i should be easy to pick out
let me ask you a question because
there's a lot of conversation now
because of jenny like
wears the same energy for mary cosby
because mary cosby actually said
atrocious things on camera so i know
multiple like so well and ramona let's
bring it back to new york so i've talked
to housewives of new york i mean ramona
has done allegedly
many racist things like and
so it's interesting it's like i get
bravo's point that like these twisted
humans like vicky gunvalson was had many
beyond beyond and and we only get to see
one percent of yes footage like you know
that there's so much problematic footage
so i think it is a slippery slope when
you start like putting everyone under a
microscope right um but jenny's stuff
was pretty but jenny also has a
housewife was top five like one of my
least favorite ever graced my screen
i'm grateful but i know you're ultra
upset about carlin
oh jackie actually so jackie ashtray is
carlin's number one fan i actually
bought a cameo from carlin before the
scandal i didn't know i don't expect her
to fulfill my cameo request now because
obviously you should her
it i did
i literally i've been waiting two weeks
for my cameo for carl and i thought it
would be a great push present for jackie
i it's not coming like it's never you
got her a carlin caviar
well you saw a little bit of time no but
like now with everything going on carl
and julie and dewey is probably the
worst housewife oh my god i just don't
even want to know what's going on in
their house right now like do you think
he's finally going to get his sister
wife
you know what maybe maybe that's what
they need so anyway i think it's good
jenny's gun she was bad energy anyway
she's so toxic um and the thing is like
these story lines i thought a lot of
people were like oh have have jenny on
so we can discuss just over the next
season i'm like these are like not that
we shouldn't be discussing racial issues
but like
taking if you're like 50 years old with
a twisted mindset like you're not going
to learn i'm sorry like call me a
pessimist i don't think we want to see
that you know and
so i actually i mean i think salt lake
is so explosive and good but it's
actually getting off the rails where
it's like these people don't even
remotely like each other there's no
chemistry
and when lisa barlow's just like i i no
longer understand where this has gone
it's true like jen shaw just unhinged
screaming for the sake of screaming okay
what do you think about meredith um
you know i think meredith needs to like
get herself back in the game because the
whole disengaging thing like let's ship
his sale and you know what she
disengaged like 11 times during that
dinner she left and came back that to
the point where like it wasn't even cool
i mean i love we we should like a cam or
a montage of all the like housewives
running away literally but actually it
would be hours and hours long of course
because every episode someone runs
someone has to go do you think
production helps like sets up you have
to go get her um yes because you know
even though i think it's technically
disruptive when someone like gets up and
walks away it's so dramatic and they
love to use that footage in a trailer
you know
so i think i think at the end of the day
they actually really like it
they need to bring they should actually
taylor armstrong i think lives in the
mountains she should rejoin salt lake
she lives in colorado same thing same
thing i actually completely agree i
think one of my favorites do you think
taylor armstrong would move to salt lake
to be a part of that cast
i think one of my favorite walk-offs in
history is when ramona walked off when
they were talking about um alex
uh van what was her name record alex
mccord sent simon van kampen's
naked photos and ramona didn't want to
be associated with it they were filming
at the russian tea room remember
wait what do you think do you think
candice bushnell is going to join
housewives of new york is that what
they're saying yeah and then she kind of
disputed it in you know whatever but
she's friends with all them and she's
thirsty yeah you know what that's
that's actually not a bad call yeah
that i could see that being the
evolution of candace bushnell yeah
i don't hate him she has a house in sag
harbor
a new show she has money like i'm down i
don't think she has a lot of money
though
financially financially like i watch
housewives for aspirational lifestyles
that's what i always say
new york does not deliver it does not
deliver one iota you know what i missed
adrian malouf i miss her energy i think
about her constantly and joyce gerard
i'm going to disagree there no but the
joyce gerard carlton
oh carlton that era of real house size
of beverly hills is living in general
appreciate it when it happened we took
it for granted let's talk about oc what
are your thoughts on what's going on
noella and what you know the travel
expert is here is it possible that
someone can travel to mexico
private with a passport card
every time she has a margarita
[Laughter]
that's really good that is what she does
i needed that i needed that oh my god um
i like oc this season last season it was
busted
heather dubrow i think heather dude bro
needs to tread a little bit lightly
trying to just be the lv she's treading
an lvp status i mean like someone and
let's just get back shannon bedour is
such a villain but like she's literally
just bringing up a lawsuit that was
public knowledge i know you know what
like and i love it when they're like you
could have told me directly the point of
filming the show has to do it on camera
tasteful for sure but we needed to know
that information do you think they
should break down the fourth wall more
like they did on girls trip i love the
fact that they talk about especially on
girls trip they were talking about like
we're on a show we're famous i love that
i don't think it works all the time yeah
but i wish sometimes like it's just so
obvious and like it's an element in in
people's fighting and they can't even
acknowledge it which is just like
frustrating because we know we're
watching girl strip was really good i
didn't like it in the beginning
who do you think came out on top of
girl's trip and who do you think came
out on my mind teresa came out really
good yeah i think cynthia bailey came
out on bottom oh she is terrible she is
painful to watch she has she was having
a drama of a 16 year old girl you didn't
want to bailey
and her questions were moronic no
totally she like i actually really like
her on atlanta i was surprised she had
such a like hard time i think they all
came out pretty good yeah kyle and
melissa were great oh wait i have to i
talked to dorinda about the blue stone
manor oh when does that go that is gonna
be explosive when does it come out um
we haven't gotten a date yet
we have not gotten a date yet and it was
filmed at her home it was last july i
think it's coming out this spring they
all stayed at her house for the night
for multiple nights vicki gumbelson like
brandon glanville
phaedra
tamra wow that sounds good unique i
think dorinda and phaedra formed an
alliance which is not shocking you've
actually been to blue stone manor can
you tell us about that
is a gorgeous facility gorgeous facility
it is kind of like a museum when you
walk around it's like even it's stunning
the grounds are gorgeous like she keeps
it really nice
she makes it nice
um and you're also the proud new owner
of a farm
i am you have horses i have now four
horses including ginger spice who's a
miniature horse miniature horse and you
can follow them on at carbon ridge oh
yeah we're just starting this social
media
and i have to do an audit of the account
immediately yeah but i will be there
this weekend yeah so you can i will be
taking content but i i just i don't have
the time to do it i don't have time to
of course not so but um it's cute the
horses are so cute i live on 30 acres i
go riding
so yeah i can't believe you haven't been
there yet i know i'm coming this weekend
brian's also coming on tour with me you
have a lot of exciting things in the
pipeline you're coming on tour with me
for the foreseeable future
i've got a new horse you're just living
your best life and you're in this
there's even some bigger things to come
hopefully this year yes
yes
to be continued to be continued so good
luck on your lawsuit the toasters are
rooting for you because you're fighting
for the man and we are the man and we
appreciate you and we love you and i
love when you come on the toast and i
just could talk to you for literally two
hours well i'm so excited to see you in
dc
parks casino i think i'll be in la san
francisco actually we're also doing a
texas week in austin
we're doing all i'm not okay we're we
are not okay collectively claudia what
is it like traveling with me
there's nothing better i have to tell
you there is nothing better you want to
know why because i think before i ever
traveled with you i had such a low
threshold for like patience and like
when the plane was delayed five minutes
i would roll my eyes so hard i thought
they wouldn't come back to the front of
my head like i was just so
inconvenienced by every minor thing
but you travel so much you just roll
with everything and you've really kind
of relaxed me as a traveler you're like
it's not that big of a deal like we'll
be out of here in 10 minutes and you get
cool souvenirs like your rash
by the way
thank you how do you think it looks oh
that's much better yeah yeah ryan was
there through the whole journey on the
rash we're on our way down no it looks
way better it's way better it's
remarkably better you were there like i
was i don't think you're going to be
able to charge for meet and greets with
your rash i thought claudia should
actually as a new revenue stream like
you could take a picture with her
because it's not contagious i think
i love you brianna thank you so much for
coming everyone follow brian on
instagram keeping up with all of its
drama with american airlines brian kelly
at brian kelly and also just a stunning
horse farm i love you you guys have a
great day this is our last show of the
week i can't wait to see you guys in dc
and philly on tour brian we'll be there
it's going to be so much fun and we'll
be exclusive explosive we'll be back on
the toast on monday have an amazing
weekend i love you and we'll see you
monday bye